this is not a drill
the pool is finally full and
the sun is finally out
so I can finally show you how the old girl turned out
we spent six weeks restoring
a 50 year old pool
all by ourselves
with no pool renovation experience
and she's pretty big and was looking pretty feral
so I won't lie I was deeply concerned at times
there was so many steps leading up to this point
but in the last part
we had just finished painting and we were
finally ready to turn on the tap
which yes for those wondering
is a hell of a lot cheaper than getting 60,000
litres of water delivered
I don't know exactly how much cheaper yet
but rest assured when I get that bill
I will tell you
and it took pretty much exactly two days to fill
but I was expecting three
and I was so fkn nervous to find out how it was gonna look
final reminder of where we started
and this is where we ended up
what do you think?
Bit of an improvement?
and can I just quietly say I'm actually so proud of this
we could have never undertaken this
when we first moved in 18 months ago
this was definitely our biggest and most
physically demanding project date
but it feels so nice and clean now
it's no longer covered in mould and infested with algae
it's no longer cracked with weird holes in the bottom
and that was just phase 1
obviously it needs furniture styling landscaping
and if you wanna see that unfold
I'm so sorry but come back for the update